a vasectomy procedure is a permanent
method of birth control for men
where the surgeon cuts and seals off a
section of the male reproductive tract
in order to prevent sperm from exiting
the man's body during ejaculation
a man's reproductive system includes the
testes - oval-shaped structures in which
sperm a man's reproductive cells are
produced leading from each testicle is
the vas deferens a tube that carries
sperm to the urethra a channel in the
penis that transports urine and sperm
during ejaculation each vas deferens
propels sperm through the seminal
vesicles and the prostate gland
structures that provide liquid
nourishment and transport for the sperm
now called semen this combination of
sperm and supporting fluids continues
its journey through the urethra and is
ejected out of the penis during
intercourse the semen passes into a
woman's reproductive system where the
sperm can meet and fertilize an egg if
you don't want to impregnate a woman you
may choose a birth control method from
one of several categories abstinence to
completely avoid pregnancy by not having
sexual intercourse contraception to
temporarily avoid pregnancy through use
of various methods during sexual
intercourse or sterilization to
permanently avoid pregnancy by having a
medical procedure a vasectomy is one
form of sterilization before the
procedure begins you will be given
injections of a local anesthetic to numb
the area
in a conventional vasectomy a scalpel
will be used to make a small incision on
one side of your scrotum the thin skin
pouch that houses the testicles your
physician will locate the vas deferens
and lift it through the incision at this
point you may feel a pulling sensation
the vas deferens will be cut and a small
piece may be removed next the newly cut
ends of the vas deferens will be tied
sealed with surgical clips or cauterized
the vas deferens will be returned to the
scrotum and the incision closed with
stitches
the same steps will be repeated on the
other side of the scrotum this procedure
takes about 30 minutes in the non
scalpel method your doctor would use a
special ringed instrument to hold and
expose the vas deferens from this point
on the procedure is the same as the
conventional vasectomy this method is
usually associated with faster healing
and fewer complications and is just as
effective as the conventional method
immediately following either procedure
you will be asked to rest at the
doctor's office for a short time the
incisions will heal in a few days with
little or no scarring after your
procedure you will need to limit your
physical activity for one to two days
you will not be able to shower for 24
hours you will need to avoid lifting
heavy objects performing hard labor and
exercising strenuously for five to seven
days you will need to avoid sexual
activity for seven days